-Good evening!
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We're so happy
you're with us tonight,
Now we're gonna get to the news.
Today was Thanksgiving,
so congrats on figuring out
your father-in-law's TV.
[ Laughter ]
"You gotta let
the tubes warm up."
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Today was Thanksgiving,
and many of us are back
in our hometowns
at the same tables
as our relatives
for the first time in two years.
But despite that,
I'd say we still have
a lot to be thankful for.
[ Laughter ]
CNN published an article
this week titled,
"To avoid COVID,
here are four questions
to ask family and friends ahead
of Thanksgiving gatherees."
"Gatherings" -- excuse me.
"Gatherees"?
Are they called "gatherees"
or "gatherings"?
I know where either one works,
right?
I'm gonna go with "gatherees."
[ Laughter ]
That's the Old English.
"Join me at a gatheree!"
[ Laughter ]
"For pickled ham!"
CNN published an article
this week titled,
"To avoid COVID,
here are four questions
to ask family and friends ahead
of Thanksgiving gatherings."
They are,
"Do you watch Fox News?
Have you watched Fox News?
Will you watch Fox News?"
and, "What do you think
of Fox News?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'm wondering
if it's less --
I'm wondering if it's
less effective
to burn them after you
pronounce it "gatherees."
[ Laughter ]
New Jersey transit officials
added additional buses
and train service today
for the Macy's
Thanksgiving Day Parade.
Unfortunately, they're running
on the exact same route.
[ Laughter ]
Tomorrow is Black Friday,
and consumers can see prices
as low as whatever the full
price was four weeks ago.
[ Laughter ]
Inflation comedy!
Actor Matthew McConaughey
discussed his possible campaign
for governor of Texas
in a new interview
with "The Hollywood Reporter,"
which is smart because
Texans famously
get all their news
from "The Hollywood Reporter."
[ Laughter ]
Rolls-Royce claimed last week
that its so-called
Spirit of Innovation plane
is the fastest
all-electric aircraft
in the world, reaching speeds of
over 345 miles per hour,
which is good
because it's already delayed
two hours out of LaGuardia.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
the fast-food chain Popeyes
released its first-ever
vegan option at its new
London location,
which is a Creole
vegan red bean patty burger.
Because if there's one
thing the English love,
it's putting beans
where they don't belong.
[ Laughter ]
"Come to my breakfast gatheree!"
That was a monologue, everybody!